I was interested in doing a martial art
and my first teacher, Terry Ezra, came to my
high school and he did a demonstration
and from the moment I saw it I just
thought "Yeah, this is great this is what
I want to do". I thought it was wonderful
Even though I was very young, the
movements and the philosophy and how it
was presented to me seemed very natural
and very logical
so as a kid it really appealed me.
My first teacher was a guy called Stephen Parn
I really should mention him because
he ran my local dojo in Chester.
He was 4th Kyu. Can you believe it he was 4th Kyu...
But in those days a lot of people were 4th Kyu,
if you were 3rd kyu you were senior grade, you know.
They were no 3rd Dan around
It was actually just post Chiba Sensei.
Chiba Sensei had left about a year or two before,
this was 1980.
So it was very much the aftermath of
Chiba sensei being there.
Kanetsuka Sensei was the technical director
he became the technical director
of the British Aikido Federation at that time.
But there was still a strong influence
from the time that Chiba Sensei was there.
And these two influences started
to diverge at that time.
So I was more
towards the Kanetsuka Seinsei side :
he became the technical director,
so he was the technical director that I knew.
I did not know Chiba Sensei from the 1980's.
Saying that in 1982 or 83,
Chiba Seinsei came back to the UK
and he taught to summer school in Lancaster,
and that was the first time I'd seen him.
And I went to San Diego after that.
When I was 16, I went for a couple of weeks
to train with him then.
So that was my first exposure to Chiba Sensei
So I'd only done Aikido
for maybe five years
and I suddenly went to this dojo...
I couldn't understand it at all...
It was a very strange experience for me
to be in that environment
You know I'd come from a small town in England
with my local dojo...
and then suddenly going to
a dojo that was called the pressure cooker.
And Chiba Sensei was very intense and very...
I mean he was at the height of his power.
I was just a visitor
and it was like sightseeing, you know.
So, he was very nice to me
but still saying that, I was very wary of him
because... the sense
of power and energy around him was scary,
and also I could see what he was doing
with his students and and his daughter.
At that time she was very young
she was training...
I was protected, really,
because I was just a visitor.
Yes I was living in England then.
A couple years later I moved down to London
to train with Kanetsuka Sensei.
I stayed there for about a year.
And then I moved to Japan
I went to japan when I was 20
Yes, Ken was one of my first teachers actually.
He lived near Chester
he was not far from Chester
and he used to come down.
Every friday evening we used to have a class
which would rotate the teachers
and Ken was one of those teachers.
So he would come down
Of course, we were very excited...
We were kids, you know,
and we were very excited that this man had tea
with O Sensei...
and he used to tell us stories and that was great.
He was a lovely guy.
Actually, before I came to Japan I went to his house
and he gave me lots of advice about living in Japan.
I'd wanted to go to Japan since I was about 16
because I'd heard about Hombu Dojo.
We didn't know a lot about Hombu Dojo in England then,
we weren't told very much about it.
But I had this goal
that I really wanted to go there
and train at Hombu Dojo.
A young japanese man came to England - Tanaka San
He was from Humbo Dojo
He said "Yes you should go
definitely it's a great experience".
In England we knew Shibata Sensei
who had been over,
we'd also seen Yamaguchi Sensei,
at that time I think Yokota Sensei
had also been to England...
So we've had some influences and some contact
with Humbu Dojo Shihan at that time.
So I went.
Yes. I mean, I went for Aikido.
I was planning to teach English,
that was going to be what I was going to do to survive.
But it wasn't so easy in the beginning :
it took me awhile to get a job.
But eventually I got a job,
so I tried to revolve my job around my training.
It depended when I was working :
I would train the morning
if I was working in the afternoon,
if I was working in the morning
I trained in the afternoon...
So I would just fit it in around my work
But, I mean, most mornings I would try to go
to Waka Sensei 's class
6:30 am class at the dojo
and then maybe an evening or an afternoon class also...
As much as I could...
Not at all. I tried to go to everybody.
I didn't discriminate at all.
The only teachers I couldn't go with
it was when I was working.
And I feel very sad now
that I never went to Arikawa's
- I think I went to one of Arikawa Sensei -
because I was working.
Sometimes it was just hard to get to them all,
but I tried to go as much as possible
to see as many as possible
I used to train a lot with Kuribayashi Sensei,
Kanazawa Sensei, Etsuji Horii Sensei,
Sugawara Sensei and Kobayashi Sensei.
They were not Ushi Deshi at that time,
they already started to teach,
so they weren't in Hombu Dojo.
They would come to Osawa Sensei's class
on the thursday morning.
Yoko Okamoto Sensei was there
and I would try to train with Yoko.
That was the period that she was raising her family,
she had her babies then...
And there was two foreign Uchi Deshi at that time
in Hombu Dojo :
Yahe Solomon and Rosso Fernandez
from New Zealand.
They were living there for a few years
Yes, I found it very very strange.
And I had a very difficult time outside the dojo.
There weren't many foreigners around
generally in Japan at that time.
We were very exotic, the people were very curious
I was scrutinized a lot
I think as a young foreign woman to, you know
So sometimes it was very hard,
it was kind of tiring, it was very tiring
to have that constantly.
I'm sure it did, definitely.
I mean, for or me that was my experience.
I can't say about the other women who were there
- they were quite a lot of american women there -
I don't know if they had the same experiences
but I know from my point of view
I had some in kind of difficult times.
And it was also very lonely
I mean, you had this sort of solitary existence where
you're going to the dojo
you're going to work
and, you know, you're tired a lot of the time
and you know you are being looked at...
It's very lonely, that kind of life
I was there three and a half years
and at the end I was ready to go
I wanted to leave.
I think for most people then they didn't consider
that it was a place they would live
it was a transient place you'd stay for 2-3 years
and then you would go
I never had any plan to do that.
I think that sounds really good
and I should have had that plan,
but I didn't,
which was a mistake.
So now, it wasn't part of a great plan I had but
that just seemed to be the finite time that I stayed there.
I never thought about the future
I never even thought about being in Japan
as being good for my resume,
or good in the sense that when or if
I become an Aikido teacher this would
look good that I was in Japan...
I never even considered that,
I just wanted to train it was all about.
It was very day to day.
And even going to San Diego
- I went to San Diego straightaway after japan -
it was only it with the thought that
I didn't want my daily Aikido to stop,
and I knew if I went back to the UK
it would stop.
So that's why I went to San Diego :
merely just to continue my daily Aikido life.
I had a good friend in Japan, Yahe Solomon,
and he recommended that I go to Chiba Sensei.
I'd already had some contact with
Chiba Sensei,
so, that was what I did. I went back there.
I didn't, I didn't take part.
I didn't want to do it
because I think my Aikido
was quite formed at that stage :
I was already 3rd Dan,
I've been training for quite a long time
since I was very young,
and I felt it wasn't really what I wanted to do.
Then I went back to the UK.
My father got very sick and he died,
so I went back to the UK
and I stayed there for three years.
Then I try to do some other stuff not just Aikido.
I had a very small group there in the UK.
That was in Chester.
But that was interesting,
It was an interesting experience to suddenly
have gone from those very intensive years of training
to suddenly not intense,
and having people that I had to teach...
And I was really stuck
I became really stuck in translating
what I've been doing into teaching.
When you actually stop
your daily training and try to open a dojo,
the reality is quite depressing.
It can be quite disappointing and
depressing, you know.
From the start you get students
who are just not as enthusiastic as you.
That's the first reality check you get.
So, if you believe that you're going to get students
come through the door who just think
you're great because you did Aikido
for 3-4 hours a day...
And I know a lot of teachers find this,
they get sick of teaching beginners
they just want to teach Yudansha,
or they just want to teach Ko Kyu Nage or...
But of course the majority of your teaching is
teaching somebody how to fall,
how to stand up, how to turn...
That's 90% of the job :
where you put your foot, where you put your hand...
That's it.
And unless you love that
then you're not going to enjoy teaching.
And also, you know,
I think it's a good experience
to have your own dojo and to be creating
your own students :
it makes you a different Aikidoka, I think.
I think the primary thing
that I personally got from Chiba Sensei
was how to run a dojo,
how to relate to people.
That was a huge part of his teaching as well :
he was good at giving you an idea
of what your responsibilities were
as an Aikidoka.
I think, depending what I'm doing,
I take different aspects
of the various teachers that I trained with.
Teaching beginners,
very often, I look to who I trained with
as a beginner, how I learned and
what spoke to me as a beginner.
So therefore my first Aikido teachers
were my biggest influences.
If I'm training with people who are a little bit more advanced
then I take something from
a teacher I trained with
when I was more advanced.
If I'm trying to give some
maybe a slightly deeper feeling of Aikido or...
then I would relate to another teacher
that I used to train with, you know...
So it very much depends on what I'm doing.
For me, of course, my situation's slightly different ;
I'm married to somebody who has a job.
I mean, this makes everything quite different.
But probably if you ask somebody who
is supporting a family through doing Aikido
then I think that it is a very precarious life...
It's not so good to be like that.
So I don't even know if it's possible
that somebody can actually
be purely professional in that sense, you know.
I think you have to be very flexible,
you have to be very open,
you have to drop a lot of your expectations...
Maybe you have to be more inclusive in what you do...
It's very hard to take a hard line as a teacher
Well, you could look at it
as dropping your standards, but...
I think you don't necessarily have to drop
your technical standards, but maybe
you just have to accept
that you're going to get people to come to your dojo
who are not going to be able to move
in the way you want :
they're going to be old,
they're going to be overweight,
they're going to be predominantly older actually
because not many young people come to Aikido...
So, in that way, you have to
adapt your standards to what's in front of you,
rather than drop your standards.
I think possibly... It's maybe a combination
of a few things :
As teachers get older, they tend to
not attract younger people, I think this is a factor.
And also I think it's people
remaining in power
when they should be disseminating power, really,
and delegating power to others,
and getting younger people to teach,
getting younger people to teach in the dojo.
I mean, we see that in Greece :
younger people teaching in the dojo
you bring younger people in.
I mean they don't want to necessarily have
a 50 years old woman like me teaching them.
That's a fact, so...
I think it's a bit troubling,
but I think if people try to hold on
to this sort of fantasy
that they are going to be the Sensei
or the teacher for ever,
I think this is quite damaging
to Aikido, and they fear letting go of something.
There needs to be some flexibility around
teaching or
getting young people more involved
in the teaching process.
And also empowering them to feel
that they have a future in Aikido.
I think it's very stacked against them,
you know : they come and it's the same people
again and again...
I think it's very calcifying for Aikido.
But, of course, it's kind of mixed
with a traditional element of Japan
which has a strong hierarchy.
But it doesn't lend itself
to much dynamism, I think.
I think that is important.
And people... white belts who are impacted by Aikido :
how is Aikido impacting their lives ?
As kyu grade, as a white belt ?
Because they're important !
We always concentrate on the Yudansha
or the teachers,
but without those people we were not here !
That's the fact.
And so, if we continually ignore them
then, in 20 years there's not gonna be anybody left
to teach.
You know, we might not be - well, you'll be around, you're young -
but I might no longer be around in 20 years,
and if you're continually sidelining
the beginners or white belts or...
I think it's a grave mistake, really,
and we'll pay the price,
we will really pay the price, you know.
A lot of classes, I think,
could be more geared towards lower grades.
Posture, Tai Sabaki... simple stuff that
we tend to lose sight of, you know.
We're flinging people around and we're looking great...
But you lose sight of
what's really fundamental
and what makes people think they're learning something.
I feel that from in my own dojo,
that people have to feel that they are
starting from somewhere and they are
progressing and getting better
and they have a base, they have a strong base.
I think that's important.
So maybe that's something that could be looked at,
that there's a fundamental class
there's a basics class for people.
Because, I think if you miss that part of the training
and the development,
then you never get that back,
you just learn techniques and they're just arbitrary
techniques that you're learning
but you have no base or foundation.
Well, I think more men do Aikido than women,
I mean generally. That's a fact.
And I'm not exactly sure why either,
maybe men are a little bit more ambitious
than women to teach...
They have a stronger will to power than women,
I think women don't naturally take
an authoritative position,
it's not in their nature...
I'm not saying it's not in all-women's nature's but mostly,
I make a generalization, you know...
But I'm not really sure why.
I guess it's just a proportion thing
that there are more men around
than women.
And I think there's a strong lack of
maybe self-confidence with women :
they are not as powerful,
they're not as physically strong as men, you know...
Of course you get small men and big women...
but generally,
women are not as physically powerful.
And I think that maybe makes them less confident,
that they don't feel that they can be teachers
or have any authority, you know.
Saying that, when I was in America,
there were many senior women
who were very good teachers
and very confident and very able to teach.
So I think it depends on the country
I think there's a big cultural element, yes.
In America the women are maybe...
they're more equal and they're more accepting
and their expectations of themselves are different,
they are very different.
But in America, definitely, there is
much more gender equality, I think.
And I think probably Yamada Sensei
and also Chiba Sensei when he was alive he did a lot
to promote women,
and they're very open to women teaching.
There are so many different sides to that...
What's going on the mat with men and women ?
I just think it's not a simple as
women not being encouraged or
men being encouraged or...
I think there's just a lot going on, you know.
This is not simple to answer this about...
Obviously there are issues that you see...
But, I personally have not been greatly affected by them any,
it's quite lucky.
But maybe I have been but haven't known about it.
I do think women have to be twice as good as men
to be rated the same. They really do.
I think you have to be exceptional as a woman...
You know, I've seen a lot of guys who are quite mediocre
and they get teaching positions
because they're strong,
they can throw people.
So that becomes the bottom line, you know.
But it's the wrong bottom line
I think probably that's the most common
complaint I've heard from women,
it's that they're constantly corrected by men.
Whatever the ability of the man is
they're just constantly corrected.
It's an assumption that the woman is not as good
as good as the man.
And I think that one is very strange :
what kind of man does that ?
I think it's very strange...
Well, I will say that
the gender issue was missing tonight [during the seminar] (laugher)
because that is a complaint I've heard
many times from women.
I mean, this is everywhere for women,
this kind of thing,
this aggression or, you know, undercutting,
and things like telling women what to do...
I mean that's just everywhere.
But I think that's how it manifests on the mat
and it's physical and it's not very pleasant,
it can be very upsetting, very very upsetting.
I don't know how that could change.
I really don't know
how that issue can be brought forward and be opened.
I mean, for me, as a female teacher,
what is red rag to my bull
is a man who does not take Ukemi for a woman.
And the man can be
much worse technically
than the woman
but he will just not take Ukemi for her.
And I've seen that on a number of occasions,
and I have to say that's one thing
that can get me really angry.
I can get very angry when I see that.
I think that's the sign of a healthy dojo
when there's a good percentage of the dojo with women.
If it's just all men...
When I'm recommending somebody to go to a dojo
I always say :
"Make sure there's a lot of women in the dojo".
Because if it is not,
then something not going right in that dojo.
It's usually a sign that something isn't going right,
definitely.
One thing I always do which, I think, helps
diminish this, definitely in my dojo
- and I think in a lot of dojos - is
I always focus on Ukemi.
When I get beginners coming in - men -
I always focus on the Ukemi
rather than the technique.
So they have an understanding
that they are falling and receiving a movement :
whatever that movement is,
how good or bad,
their job is to fall.
And I think when you emphasize that
it really changes the dynamic.
And I get them to fall by themselves,
I don't make them fall, you know.
That solo practice of Ukemi,
I think it helps them understand, you know :
you're not waiting necessarily to be thrown,
that is a practicing of itself.
Not intentionally, no.
Whether people perceive something else ?
I don't know. Maybe they do, maybe they don't...
It's very difficult to judge what you transmit
when you are teaching...
I mean, I don't talk about anything esoteric
or anything like that...
Sometimes I talk about "internal expansion",
"moving from the centre"...
But I don't talk about any "spirituality"
or, you know, any "meditative stage"
Well, you know, as a teacher you always like to see
somebody behaving well
and doing not only good Aikido
but doing Aikido in a good responsible way
and in a caring way
- looking after the Uke -
making sure that they're doing not only clear technique
but they're showing good character.
I mean, I think that's very important,
and quite often you don't always see those two together...
Somebody can be very very good at Aikido
but not necessarily display good character
Quite often it manifest physically.
If mentally they're not there
it will manifest.
So, it is quite hard, actually, to just separate those two
...
No, I don't think it does...
It can...
but it doesn't just by doing it.
I think if you practice well and with sincerity
and really care about your partner,
then it makes you a better person.
But just the act of doing Aikido,
arbitrarily no, it doesn't just make you a better person.
I think that's the dream, but it doesn't.
I knew my husband from when I was 16.
He used to come over from Dublin
with the Irish Aikido group
to the BAF summer schools and I knew him from there.
And I met him again in 1995 in America,
because I'd gone back to America
for a couple of weeks and he was
going to stay there for six months.
So I met him and he invited me to come Greece
to teach a seminar.
So that's how it happened : I came
and then I moved to Greece to be with him.
He already had a dojo in Greece, and a group
And then I came over and we ran it together.
It's gone, I would say, from being a very small activity
to suddenly mushrooming in the last six-seven years
So now there are tens and tens of dojos around...
We try as best as we can to collaborate on to
this potential IAF recognition, if you call it that
we are we're all working together to achieve this
which is great we're all on board with that.
There's a lot of different seminars
that happen in Greece
so, you know, we try to support
as many seminars as we can.
We have Sugawara Sensei or Kobayashi Sensei
come over from Hombu Dojo
so this is a joined seminar
with all of the Hombu recognize groups within Greece,
we all are inviting those teachers...
I feel exactly the same.
I will always be a student of Hombu Dojo.
For me that hasn't changed at all...
It makes no difference
Like I'd always think :
"could I take good Ukemi for Sugawara Sensei"
"could I take good Ukemi for Kobayashi Sensei"...
That would always be my primary thought.